hello and welcome to our full video
review of judgment
I'm here with reviewer Edmund Tran who's
going to tell us all about his thoughts
on the game now of course if you guys
are looking for our full written review
you can find that on site what we're
gonna do here in this video is dig into
more of the nitty-gritty of the features
story Kombat and everything else you
might want to know but let's start off
with your overall take away from
judgment right so judgment is the latest
game from Rio Kotaku Studios who did the
yeah because again so if you plenty yeah
cos again before you'll know exactly
what to expect if you like those games
then you'll like judgment like turn the
video off now just go play it you know
you know read my full review it which
has been more concise but yeah I'll dig
into some of the nuances of what these
games are about and what's good and
what's bad and what's in there so yeah
judgment overall I really really liked
this game I'm a huge fan of the series I
played almost every single game the last
two Yakuza six and yeah cuz I'd want me
to probably like some of my favorites
judgment doesn't quite hit those highs
because it isn't as ambitious as six or
climbing two and it adds a few new
things to the series that don't really
work out so I'll ask you a bit more
about that later but let's just start
off with what's what's the setting
what's the story that's pulling you
through judgment so in judgment you play
a disgraced defense attorney to private
investigator the whole thing about the
defense attorneys and the whole Japanese
legal system is that it's very hard to
get a criminal off a trial like the
prosecution basically always wins
which is why games like Phoenix Wright
are so exciting because it's an
impossible obstacle that they're going
up against same deal with this one so he
defended a criminal in his past he got
him off and then that criminal ended up
committing more crimes trying to avoid
too many spoilers but yeah basically
he's now a private private investigator
for hire and he somehow stumbled into
this serial killer case so people are
dying all across camera show with where
the game is set what starts off as a
seemingly straightforward murder mystery
investigation eventually spirals out
into like a really big conspiracy and
while they like you know the police the
government Yakuza of course
and you know powers beyond that it's
unsurprising that you know it's still
it's a very gripping sort of Japanese
drama mystery that's that's really
really good like I was kind of like
hooked all the way through so what are
the new kind of mechanics that are
offered in because of the protagonist
being a detective
so yeah got me the the protagonist is a
detective and naturally you'll do sort
of private investigator style things but
he also does a bunch of stuff that Kiryu
is known for in the yuccas games which
is beating the [ __ ] out of people so
there's a lot of fighting still but
there is also quite a bit of this
tailing and chasing stuff unfortunately
the tallien chasing stuff gets really
old really quick and I think judgement
is sort of the most basic bare-bones
style of tailing that you can get so for
example there are predetermined hiding
spots the people you tail are obviously
really really suss all the time so they
are always turning around and like
trying to spot you which means that
tailing always takes a super long time
after the first or second time I was
basically instantly sick of it then it
comes up a lot because you know Yagami
is a detective and he you need to do
stuff a lot chases are the other one
which are you know fast running
sequences but despite the thoughts of
pace there's still like really boring
yeah so the whole thing is like it's an
order running game when you're pushing
Yagami down the street whatever and
you're turning him left and right to
avoid like down traffic cones and like
jump ever
like pedestrians and use QuickTime
events to sort of dodge people and all
that kind of stuff which is you know
seems exciting and there's like maybe
one or two sequences where you get to
like ride a skateboard which is probably
seen in the trailers and that's really
cool that there are a lot of taste
sequences and they're basically all the
same and so you are just like getting
into these order on sequences where
you're just doing like QuickTime events
again and again and again they never
really get interesting anything that
wasn't already in a yeah the game just
feels really bad bones it sort of tacked
on yeah which is a shame because yes it
like perfectly suits the themes and the
occupation of Yagami and you know he's
character and sort of I know they want
to try and get you into the detective
story but it's just boring yeah that
seems like a massive missed opportunity
it is a mess miss opportunity
another thing about judgment that is a
bit of a shame is the fact that it only
takes place in camera Roadshow that
might seem like a bit of a weird thing
to say but you think about all the past
Yakuza games and each of them after the
first one has had a secondary city for
you to free roam around in and like do
activities and do missions in that
judgment doesn't have that at all so
it's only camera Cho that can get a bit
stale after you know the 4050 hours that
you spend in this game especially
because yak is a six and kilometer just
came out last year so this is a camera
that's only slightly changed there are
like a few more interiors but for the
most part it is the same if you've been
following this series you might get
bored more quickly than someone whose
first time to camera show is in judgment
well let's talk about where the game
shines like one of the particular
aspects that really drew you to continue
enjoying your entire playthrough where
the game really shines is in its story
and characters this game is notable
because the Yakuza series you know it's
a ten year series and we've been
following cosmic here you and a bunch of
his friends sometimes on the
protagonists as well but basically all
those characters are gone now and this
is like a fresh batch of new faces and
basically like most of the characters
that you interact especially the
protagonist Yagami and his partner
keiter
who's an ex yeah cos oh you know this
might not being a yeah cos again this
there is so much yet because there's
stuff in this we're just fine but
they're just two really enjoyable and
likable and believable protagonists the
to have a really nice sort of bromance
dynamic they like crack jokes at each
other at one of those expense that
they're like they all had their personal
faults which come out and explored
throughout the the whole story they're
each had their own character arcs and by
the end of the game you're like you will
you want to spend more time as them like
you they feel like they're your best
friends they're just two really great
guys yeah and the supporting cast is the
same a lot of them are very likeable one
of the things I really appreciated
playing through it which reminded me of
Yakuza 6 was the strength of the side
cases you can take on they still had
that creativity and charisma to me yeah
it's not a it wouldn't be a really good
toku studio game if you didn't just have
just the wackiest [ __ ] they take the
from the side cases that yeah give me
take
as part of his private investigation
business and as it expect with the P I
work sometimes it's like really mundane
stuff and sometimes it's really weird
stuff and there's a there's a lot of
weird stuff in this game like don't
don't think for a moment that the
perverseness the series has gone away
and that kind of like wacky Japanese
humor is still there in the psychic
not so much in the super serious murder
mystery but yeah it's it's there and
it's funny yeah well let's shift now
onto something that is again similar but
a little bit different to the mainline
yok is a games which is the combat how
did you find that I saw enough it's
weird like whenever you get into a new
yak is a game it feel always feels
really really stiff and slow so I
started off thinking judgments combat
was quite clunky because Yagami has a
kung-fu style he has two stances he has
the crane style and the tiger style so
the crane style is used to sort of deal
damage to crowds and when you first
start off his combo speed and sort of
movements a really slow and the crane
style is very flashy and acrobatic and
Yagami you know because he's basically
styles of Kung Fu it's it's a lot of
flips in sort of twirling on the arms
and all that kind of stuff so at first I
felt like you know he was doing way more
flipping than he was like hitting people
but the game has an upgrade system of
course and once you start upgrading his
attack damage and his combos speed and
start giving him more techniques in his
Tiger style it becomes a lot more
satisfying Tiger style is focused on
like single target damage and there are
enough interesting new things in that
style that keep the fights interesting
all the way throughout so for example
you know Yagami has the typical you know
press square a bunch of times and then
hit triangle and get different moves he
also has a techniques which require like
precise timing to execute them and get
full damage out of them yeah and
speaking about like a barracks before he
also has a you sort of wall jump where
he can you know down surf a wall and
then do an attack or a special mover for
that or we can leap for our enemies and
do attacks up in that as well the
special heat moves from the Yakuza
series where you get into its particular
sort of position and you hit a button
after charging meter and
use the environment like beat down your
enemy in a really brutal way back in
judgment as well and they code like he X
moves I mean I feel like there's a lot
more opportunity to do this more
frequently some around Yagami always
feels like he has a lot of meter you
spend on that stuff which keeps things
like flashy and fun I like this fighting
system it reminds me a lot of you know
classic like Sega beat em up games and
that's what you'll be doing in this game
it's being up a lot of people despite
being a detective you still be down a
lot of people oh yeah he's he's he's
really good fighter and like it they
don't ever explain like how ego is
massive like massively godlike kung-fu
skills like they say like oh I picked up
some things yeah I'm self-taught oh my
dad told me like nuts never delved into
which is kind of funny but that's you
know that's video games yeah I'm just
glad it's still it's very like versatile
and forgiving I mean picking up a
bicycle and beating down five dudes at
once I'm swinging it around it's still a
totally viable way of combat it's a it's
a nice system it lets you mash if you
want to and just cheese battles if you
want to but you can also get really
intricate with it and like it normally
occurs again they're like the late game
bosses were just like one-on-one fight
so that really really tests your
fighting ability so yeah it's that still
solid alright well we did receive one
question on Twitter from Brett a Woodman
see who asked how does judgments
open-world such activities differ from
Yakuza's and if they do differ how do
they differ well then if for a bit if
you play your games before there's a lot
of side activities and sort of
distractions that you'll have become
accustomed to so there's things like
mahjong shaggy casino games card games I
love the sort of arcade machines from
Club Sega back then there's also a few
new ones there's always a few new ones
so this time around one of the new ones
is fighting Vipers which was a much
underrated fighting game for the Sega
Saturn in the 90s and Virtua Fighter 5
makes a return as well they've also
included about maybe three brand new
things so one of them is pinball Yagami
has a pinball machine in his office
another is a game called camera of the
Dead which is a riff of Sega's House of
the Dead which is a light gun game and
the third is a very robust sort of VR
Mario Party our board game that you go
in
- and like Yagami puts in like these VR
goggles and he's in like a real world
ball game that to you is just a board
game so it's it's great it's a really
great way of making a shitload of money
the whole thing is like it's a board
game when you roll the dice you move a
bunch of squares and on a square you'll
get like an event I'll be getting back
in a prize you'll have to do a mini game
like unlock a door or you might just get
into a fight with like certain sort of
conditions and I think yeah that that's
really interesting it has a bunch of new
boards yeah you can play that for a long
time it's surprisingly robust and the
rewards in it a massive unfortunately
you do need to collect actual play
passes - yeah probably because the
rewards can net you like hundreds of
thousands of yen yeah but if you're
getting into fights consistently in the
game now - yeah totally
and there's also weirdly drone racing
yoga me and Kaito have a drone that they
use for detective investigation stuff
which is fine you know use it a handful
of times in the campaign and that's
surprisingly robust - and I kind of like
these minigames way more than the clan
creator stuff is at 6 in Kalama -
because I thought those were you know
their foes strategy but they were like a
bit too simple for me just spam that
stuff this stuff is a nice distraction
you don't have to get into it if you
don't want to but it's robust enough for
you to spend some time with it it's if
you want to alright well is there
anything else you think people should
know going in as part of your final
overall take away oh really I mean
judgement is very much here cuz again
despite its name despite its new
mechanics if you know if you love the
yuccas a series which I do
I think this games are great and they
have a big cult following and you'll
like judgment as well you know it's it
might not shine as bright as you as a
6-cell climate - in my eyes but if you
yeah if you like the series and you're
gonna like judgment it's a good game the
characters great the stories are great
um even though the new stuff there are a
few missteps
I don't regret playing at all you know
I'd still recommend someone who enjoys a
pizza to play this game yeah they're all
the same but they all have really really
great stories and characters there you
go all right well solid game if you guys
want to know more do check out our full
review on site leave your comments in
the comment section below and we'll see
you next time